camera is here I'm here that's how your
name is in my head yeah the naked-wasted
it's a good energy water energy behind
it drunken energy yes I just was
actually doing some rewatching of early
episodes of the show like how early like
season 3 oh that's my first year yeah
did you used to go by Tammy and then
went by Tamara when you joined the show
yes Tammy with Ladera realities no one
ever asked me that so my I was born
Tamra sue Waddell you can laugh at that
last name and when growing up my mom
would call me Tammy when I got on the
show there already was it Tammy
yes Knickerbocker yep Tammy
Knickerbocker so when I got hired I
member on the phone like really I got
hired I got hired and I'm like you know
I know there's already another Tammy
that my real name is Tamara and they're
like okay we're calling you Tamara and
Garrett was so we have the Real
Housewives of Orange County to thank for
you going by your birthday my birthday
yeah well cheers to Tammy and cheers to
Tamra
[Music]
this season it's fun it's fun we're back
to having fun we're a friends it's a big
change from the last time I sat down
with you you were ready to see Vicki bye
bye there's the door like if she could
just go home bye-bye
I'd be very happy good thought that a
lot changed on reunion day well it's
amazing what happens when somebody
actually says I'm sorry and admits that
they were wrong and you know what I can
do with that all I can say is like it's
good we're moving forward do we not
think about the past once well me and
Shannon we're talking to the day and I'm
like she was talking about I talked to
Vicki tan like what happened to us it
really got soft didn't we
all of a sudden Shannon and Tamra come
rolling back and they form this bond and
Here I am left on the side of the road
I'm a writer died kind of a girlfriend
Vicki is a fair-weather friend Kelly is
now experiencing some growing pains in
her relationship with Vicki yes it looks
a lot like what you went through and
what Shannon I don't think Vicki
means to do wrong her friends but I
think it just happens like she just
doesn't think about it like she even to
this day she'll go I didn't do anything
wrong
right I'm like Vicki you set up Michael
with one of your friends then you double
dated and then you purposely didn't tell
Kelly because you know she's gonna be
mad something there is wrong and she's
like I do it again I'm like Oh Vicki so
on that fight there they'll take her two
years to apologize
just so you know that's a scene yeah
you're on team Kelly it for that
argument there how could you not yeah my
shoulder do you think they'll get back
in a good place
um well we'll find out after the reunion
show we'll know more after that at the
reunion things get all brought up again
and emotions and then fight start and
then everybody gets in their worst so I
I'm predicting that yeah you're gonna do
a goddamn in straitjacket intervention
right now we know you and Shannon are
gonna get into it a little bit this year
we do I call it tough love because she
was not moving forward
she was dwelling on every text message
she got from from her ex and everything
like it was just overwhelming to her and
I was going through my own stuff I can't
be strong for everybody right so I gave
her a little tough love
a little kick in the pants you know you
always have that one kid you gotta yell
at the other ones you can reason with
that the one go to yell at to get the
message yeah yep so I'd yell and that's
what it takes for Shannon didn't you get
the message after that she's doing great
now great this season on the Real
Housewives of Orange County have you had
to sum up the rest of the season with
one word what would it be exciting I
mean it's the whole season I think
honestly you can't even summon up with
one word because coming off a season
that wasn't that great this one is just
so real and open and it's just real life
things are going on friendships are
tested and at the end I mean we're all
almost all of us are pretty good well
cheers to that
cheers to fun being back in the OC yes
[Music]